this is a lecture I thought would never
come namely the last one I first I think
got involved in world history and 1983
when I became part of a world history
project that produced a textbook that
was never published that I did this and
that and finally got in another textbook
project ended up with the textbook that
I've asked you all to to read in this
course which is the earth and its
people's a global history and now having
had a chance to think about and talk
about every chapter and every aspect of
the book over a period of 50 lectures
I'm finally down to the sort of
concluding reflections on this
enterprise in world history
I think that the place I would start is
with the subtitle of the book a global
history as we were debating the table of
contents and interacting with the
publisher the publisher was very
insistent on a distinction between world
history and global history the publisher
said that within the textbook trade
world history implied a collection of
discrete histories that would be for
different parts of the world and the
books tended to be organized by world
parts whereas a global history would
assume a an integrative approach in
which different parts would be written
about but in the fashion that would
integrate them into a broader more
interconnected vision of history and
that sounded good particularly because
we had decided that we are going to have
a theme oriented book with technology in
the environment and diverse the
indominus as the two themes that
appeared to us to be applicable to all
places in all times all social
situations all political situations and
that therefore we would not have any
operative assumption that there was a
discrete number of policies or
civilizations for societies to be
covered nor that there nor that there
would be any hierarchy among them would
be simply that we would in a generally
chronological fashion talk about how
these two themes manifest themselves and
their impact on human affairs
over centuries and millennia and if some
societies were talked about more than
others or less than others
it would not be either explicitly or
implicitly because of the ascription of
some superiority to the more talked
about cultures as opposed to the less
talked about cultures and the the the
broad narrative arc through the entire
book would be global integration so that
we would talk about how things started
with geographical dispersion
although thematic analogies and
gradually over the course of the
millennia it points of intersection
occurred and eventually we have the 20th
century and the increasing or the 19th
20th century the increasing reality of a
world society a world culture and of
course the Magnificent concept of
globalization whatever might be now that
I've come to the end of talking about
this I think that this was a not a very
good subtitle that is a problem with the
notion of global history it isn't the
problem of it being a globe I mean the
choices that you have are not between a
spherical geographic entity as opposed
to a planar geographical entity for
example a landscape inscribed on the
back of the turtle floating in a cosmic
sea it doesn't make a whole lot of
difference because it could just be one
big turtle and one glow
and yet when people thought about the
earth as a sphere
wherever they did it and whenever they
did it there were differences in their
imaginings of what was on the surface of
the sphere or what was on the back of
the turtle or what was on whatever you
know a super imposed structure they
imagined you know what was there under
heaven for example to think of it so the
Chinese concept of it and nobody knew
what was on the globe so the notion of a
global integration of a global history
is deceptive because it suggests that
that the globe was always one thing and
it just took a lot of time for it to
come together
if I were rewriting world history as a
science fiction novel which I think
would be a good way to do it I would
have a series of planets and they would
not know of each other's existence each
one would be a globe you would have a
globe that was the Western Hemisphere
you would have a globe that was
Australia or in Australia and and New
Zealand New Guinea and so on you would
have a globe probably that would be
Africa south of the Savannah belt and
you would have a globe that would be the
the erosion macro continent including
India and and North Africa as a southern
coastal Mediterranean Sea within these
in these globes these planets you would
have societies that develop that know
who they are know who else is there
interact
develop you know closer or more distant
relations with the other inhabits of the
planet maybe have Wars maybe have trade
but they would be separate ok that's not
particularly extraordinary perhaps as a
starting point but then you think of
people from one of these globes mainly
the macro Eurasian globe and they get
they find out about the other planets
and they find out that those other
planets have humanoid in the native
inhabitants okay I don't know where
those native inhabitants came from they
don't have the foggiest idea where they
came from because they had their own
myths or scientific theories about where
they came from and they had no way of
accounting for the people on these other
planets but they were there and they
were more or less like them whether they
were the same species was something that
was widely debated but then you have an
interaction among planets which in a
science fiction novel you would call
terraforming that is to say the people
from the from the Eurasian globe
proceeded to turn the other planets into
livable homes for themselves they had
additionally virtually no interest in in
what was transpiring among the humanoid
populations of these other planets they
did know what they wanted minerals
foodstuffs exotic plants and animals
they didn't want the people in
particular unless as it turned out they
could ship
both from from Planet Africa to Planet
America and enslave them but the
overwhelming interest of the of the
people on the erasin planet was to
exploit the other planets according to
their own concept of what exploitation
consists of and to to either destroy or
demean or ignore or try to wish away or
displace the humanoids who are living in
the other planets were that they were
exploiting know with any luck they would
all die of disease or they could be
pushed off into a reservation or they
could be enslaved the important thing
was that they not interfere with the
great terraforming plans of the people
from the erosion planet if you read a
novel like dune by Frank Herbert or go
to the movie Avatar or any number of
other science fiction venues you'll
discover that this theme of discovery
extraction oppression and terraforming
is one of the most recurrent ideas that
speculative writers of the last hundred
years have returned to now they return
to it because they see this as as an
area for imaginative creativity and
storytelling but there's also I think
underlying it a real truth that is not
often
articulated so that if you if you run
into science fiction from eccentric
locations it doesn't have the same
themes if you read the for example the
Sun City trilogy which was is the first
big work of Chinese science fiction
it has though it's some other planets
and so forth but you read it and you
realize that it is completely immersed
in a concept of a universe that is
predicated on Chinese culture Confucian
values and so forth and so on
very little resemblance to what you
would get with the European science
fiction writer so what I came to to to
focus on as I was thinking of all this
is how how incredibly exploitative the
the Western tradition has been and
continues to be and promises to be in
the future in thinking of globalization
being the final completion of the total
conquest of everybody except us okay
that's not a dramatic conclusion to come
to but it leads to to some other
thoughts
for example 200 years ago
Sumer and s Syria for example much less
the Hittites or other peoples were known
only as names in the Bible so that in
the Bible you could run into
Nebuchadnezzar or Balthazar or
Sennacherib but you didn't know anything
about them they were simply names of
people who were oppressing the Jews
usually because that's the narrative of
Jewish history and and then it all
changed because people discovered the
languages discovered the ruins and
invented or rediscovered or raised for
interpretation a vision of a culture of
many cultures that had not previously
been known so in the course of
archaeological investigation great
libraries of cuneiform documents were
discovered in Iraq and and the language
was deciphered the writing system was
deciphered the language was understood
and then we had a history the same thing
for for ancient Egypt the ancient
Egyptian language was deciphered same
thing for the Hittites
there are still
numerous languages before which we have
surviving text that we where we cannot
read the text we don't know the language
or we don't know how the writing system
relates to a language but essentially
the first half of a world history course
or a global history course like this one
is largely devoted to material that was
unknown 200 years ago and so we we teach
it and say this is the history of the
world as if we still we've already
reached a finite body of knowledge that
is this history and then what we
discover is that these histories that we
have discovered that were previously
unknown become basis for modern
nationalism modern definitions of
identity modern relations among states
and cultures and archaeology becomes a
source often a contested source of of
modern identities where you you look
back into the archaeology and you find
out who you were so that when Saddam
Hussein was rebuilding parts of ancient
Babylon when he chose to put his name on
each brick he was consciously imitating
ancient assyrian practices of babylonian
practices of putting the name of the
ruler on the bricks he's trying to to
create himself in the image of the great
ruler of the past when the shah of iran
of lamented memory who was overthrown in
1979 adopted the title area mayor he was
adopting a title that means the light of
the Aryans area was aryan Macker light
and as the light of the Aryans he was
the the modern incarnation of rulers
that went back to the 5th century BC and
that were totally unknown except for you
know uncertain biblical references we're
totally unknown 200 years ago but now
they become part of his identity and by
extension his country's identity so that
in 1977 no 71 when you have the Shah of
Iran sponsoring a national celebration
of 2500 years of continuous Iranian
Imperial greatness and extracting money
from everyone in the country to pay for
the celebrations it really was believed
I think that this saw actually thought
that he was the continuation even though
there is no way in the world that you
have 2500 years from continuous irani
Imperial greatness because the Arabs
came in and conquered the places ruled
it for several hundred years without the
Iranians being in charge and then the
Turks came and did the same but this was
the use of history as myth but the myth
was very you know the the substance of
the myth was very old but the roots of
the method were very recent
you have it now in an extremely
contested form in Israel / Palestine to
what degree does archaeology validate
the identity of Palestinians or validate
the identity of of Jewish Israelis it is
so disputed we have we had a big dispute
here of course with one faculty member
from Barnard but a more dramatic example
was a Lebanese historian named Kemal
Salemi
who wrote a it actually was probably the
most distinguished 11 days historian at
least among the half-a-dozen
most distinguished lebanese historian of
the of the last generation he wrote a
book called the Bible came from Arabia
and that was devoted to the thesis that
everything that happens in the Torah the
first five books of the Bible the sacred
text of the Jews refers to locations
that are south of Mecca between Mecca
and Yemen and do not refer to what we
call the Holy Land his argument was a
fill illogical argument he said when you
take all the place names from the from
the Torah or even past the Torah to the
period of judges and kings and
chronicles you take all those place
names and you try and find them on a map
and correlate them with the archaeology
you can't find any of the places the
place names have all disappeared you may
find a place that has an old pot you can
say Jewish pot but you know the pot
doesn't say you know I am a Jewish pot
here in in Bethel or something like that
it's it's a matter of conjecture
so what Celebi said was
all those place names that cannot be
found in the holy land are right there
on the map in Arabia in exactly the
relationship to each other
that would be predicted on the basis of
the Bible so that take one of the most
dramatic ones is the case of Jordan you
know I looked over Jordan and saw the
land of milk and honey
if you go to Jordan and you stand where
Moses stood looking over the Jordan
River you say am I looking at a land of
milk and honey say no I'm looking at a
desert because of Jordan Valley is a
basically a desert but saliba said in
the Aesir province south of Mecca there
is a long escarpment and the name of
that escarpment in Arabic is order done
which is the Arabic word for Jordan and
it's not a river but it's a line of
cliffs and if you look over the cliffs
you see a fertile valley below and he
says that's the land of milk and honey
that was interesting
the likelihood of Sallee B being correct
hovers very close to zero but his book
was translated into many European
languages and really celebrated in
Europe because it's fundamentally an
anti-semitic work in the United States
he would could never find a publisher
because the United States is far more
committed to to the integration of
Jewish and non-christian and other
non-jewish populations and the Europeans
are who still don't always get it so
sleevee who had to play certain fill
logical tricks even to write the book
yeah I'd say well you know I asked him
you think your book is right he said who
knows now if we ever did it in the
archaeology in Saudi Arabia we might
find out but the Ark the Saudis aren't
going to allow that and so we'll just
put it up
a conjecture Saliba himself at an
earlier stage in his career maintained
that the Lebanese were not Arabs that
they were Phoenicians and that they are
entirely different from Arabs who were
desert barbarians they were
sophisticated traders who had built
Carthage and great civilization and then
he went out of his past his Phoenician
stage became an Arab nationalist and so
on so he's a flaky historian but what he
was doing is done in a less dramatic
fashion by historians all the time who
are working on material very frequently
recently discovered material or recently
interpreted material to use it to shape
notions of the past that will be
operative going forward clearly Saliba
had a mind that if he could show that
the Jews were from the Holy Land then
there'd be all the reason for them to
leave because it wasn't their home it
was a blatantly instrumentalist type of
historical you know fact mongering okay
so the world history to me right now is
necessarily vastly different from the
world history that we would have written
200 years ago because we have found out
so much more and what we have found out
has been used so dramatically to create
identities and support political
movements and intellectual enterprises
and so forth so that maybe think what
will world history be like a hundred
years from now because after all if the
content of world history is subject to
to revision on the basis of stuff that's
been found in the last hundred years or
200 years then you know it's obvious
that what's discovered over the next
hundred years or 200 years it has a
potential to completely undermine the
world history that we right now and
people can look back and look at today's
world history textbooks and say well
weren't those were those foolish no of
course there's no way to predict what
will be discovered nor is there any
reason to to assume as a necessary
assumption that that we will uncover
some currently unknown but profoundly
important civilization or that some
language will be will be hit upon some
inscriptions that will change everything
and yet it would be very naive to think
that we're not going to because we're
continually finding finding new things
this finding of new things is
appreciated often very slowly in the
history profession because historians
don't like to go back and rewrite what
they wrote before on a different basis I
may have mentioned in this class I can't
remember that I was in the years when I
was a junior faculty member at Harvard
where serious things were never
discussed with junior faculty members
there is one meeting where we were
actually invited to be part of the
debate on whether African history should
be taught at Harvard and the debate was
fairly lively and there were senior
professors of great dignity whom I will
not name who argued that no we should
not teach African history in this
department because the Africans did not
write
their history hence there is no African
history I don't recall I as I recall I
boldly raised my hand and said yes but
if we wrote Greek history 200 years ago
from the text and then we write it now
after 200 years of archeology we write a
completely different Greek history and
isn't it likely that African history
will emerge despite the lack of of
currently available texts through the
increasing work being done in archeology
and other technical efforts to recover
the past in Africa and the worthy
gentleman who was actually one of the
few members of Department and do
anything about African history reapplied
yes but the Greeks built in stone and
the Africans build in mud
end of debate we will not teach African
history and then about two years later
they hired their first African Astoria
and deliberately had a search around the
world to find the most conservative
African Astoria they could possibly find
who would not do anything that would in
the slightest intersect African American
political interests in contemporary
America
this clearly was before Harvard hired
Cornel West and and yet this is the the
nature of the field it tends to be
conservative and reluctant to find new
things and yet the political arena and
the intellectual arena outside the
Academy are much more likely to grab on
to something new one thing I think that
will happen
over the next hundred years is that the
the civilizations of the Western
Hemisphere will become as important as
the Sumerians or the Egyptians or the
Assyrians
in the thinking about world history and
they will become important not just
because of the accumulation of the
archaeology but because I suspect we're
going to find countries that begin to
rewrite their history in terms of their
pre-columbian existence increasingly and
less and less on the basis of their
European migration so that countries
like Peru and Bolivia and Chile and
probably Beck Zuko and the various
Central American countries between
Mexico and South America I think are
probably going to move away from having
historical narratives that are
predicated on know what the
conquistadores did and more and more on
what was done before them and what was
great and what was impressive
and on the idea that they're still there
they're there the people and they can
look back to that civilization in the
same way that Saddam Hussein looked back
to the to the civilizations of ancient
Mesopotamia when he put his names on the
name on the bricks of Babylon so I if
that is done the whole adventure of the
of the terraforming Eurasians coming to
the new world may start to be seen in a
different light they may not be seen as
the creators of a great civilization or
the people who are continuing a great
civilization from Europe and gifting the
Americas with it we might be seeing as
people who were not just destroyers of
empires like the Incas and the Aztecs
the people who utterly changed
everything and not necessarily for the
good
it interests me somewhat that when you
look at stereotypes for pre-columbian
America you you know whether it's an
Indiana Jones or Donald Duck goes to
Peru or whatever it is you know Tintin
you see stereotypes with a certain type
of imagery and you say oh we know that
that's what the Mayan imagery looks like
or that's what Aztec imagery looks like
well recently I've been looking at a lot
of mochi pottery LeBeau J's civilization
was in Peru in the contemporary with the
Roman Empire and they produced you know
vast quantities of pottery you know
pottery that shows up not just in
ceremonial centers and large urban
buildings but it shows up in the small
villages it shows up everywhere in
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
specimens some of them are hand you know
hand fabricated some of them are made
from molds but one of the striking
things about them is how realistic they
are let us say if you if you take a a
portrait sculpture by a Roman artist or
a Greek artist where the portrait has
been meant to to show a specific
individual you can compare it with a
portrait head in three dimensional form
of pottery from mochi and you will see
every bit as much skill of rendering
something in a completely realist ashen
you don't have some sort of squat
unreadable thing with strange things
sprouting out of orifices and feathers
and so forth that you think of with a
Mayan images instead you have a totally
realistic tradition do you what do you
do I mean realism has been thought of in
art history as being one of the things
that you gradually achieve in the course
of of aesthetic development and here you
have realism so then you look farther
and you you say well what did they do
with their pottery and you see warriors
you see animals you see people who are
fishing in the sea and you see people
having sex the most extensive diverse
and elaborate erotic art perhaps ever
made is in these these mochi pots you
know just go to Google Images and type
in mochi pottery and you know and don't
let your you know your your kids sisters
see it it's it's steamy stuff and yet it
bespeaks a culture that clearly puts
erotic relations on a very very
different plane from those that you find
in on the Eurasia planet
now do you simply ignore that you say
well you know Europeans came to
Massachusetts and you know they you know
burned witches and oppressed anyone who
had illicit sexual relations and that
brought civilization to the new world or
do you say hello well let's actually
think about what would it mean to have a
culture like that or what would it mean
that I've mentioned this before what
would it mean to have a culture that
quit where hallucinogenic experiences at
the very center of the culture at the
very highest levels down to the lowest
levels a culture that believed in
getting in having hallucinogenic
experiences rather than simply getting
pie-eyed drug which is not very
interesting maybe the first half hour
so you'll have a different different
culture and then you have to deal with
the question of what do you do with with
a cultural heritage in which you have
human sacrifice now
if you if you go to another planet and
you find that the humanoids there have
orgies and get completely wasted on
hallucinogenic drugs and have human
sacrifice and so forth the people who
are doing the terraforming try to
distance themselves from that that we
don't that's totally different for us
and so the Europeans invented the myth
of cannibals which isn't entirely a myth
but the idea that well these people on
these other planets they're cannibals
they're headhunters they're you know
spawn of Satan everyone knows that and
so you you categorize them in ways that
totally dehumanize them and you are able
to to ignore their culture and instead
say that your values are paramount why
are they paramount well first because
they're yours and secondly because
you're able to kill everybody who
doesn't agree with you now the human
sacrifice particularly interesting
were there more people killed a human
sacrifice in the Western Hemisphere
before the Europeans came then humans
killed in the course of warfare in on
the erasure planet well probably not
because warfare in the erasure planet
killed huge numbers of people but they
weren't classified to sacrifice they
were classified as war dead it would
appear that in the new world war dead
were not nearly as interesting as you
know people killed on the altar or
killed a sacrifice but you know from the
point of view of the Achille
it doesn't make all that much difference
perhaps whether you were killed in war
or whether you were killed in sacrifice
it's very hard to know except that we
have fairly good into indications that
the the sacrifice victims in the new
world got stoned before they before they
were killed which may have been a little
better than being killed him or who
knows but what is more striking to me is
that the the erasure planet people when
we got to the new world what they what
really struck them very profoundly was
there weren't any animals to eat they
were going to have to hunt instead of
having animals so they could simply kill
and eat the local people had never
created a culture based on having
captive animals that they killed an
eight
the Europeans could not imagine not
killing animals meeting them was strange
enough to have vegetarians in India and
and elsewhere but in those other places
at least there were some people who are
still willing to kill and eat animals
killing and eating animals
was so central to what it was to be a
human for for Europeans that they
couldn't really imagine how you could
have a land that didn't have animals
that were killed and eaten is there a
relationship between sacrificing humans
and sacrificing animals the Europeans
were perfectly comfortable with
sacrificing animals no killing animals
and then eating them afterwards and yet
if you killed a human and then ate it
afterwards that was barbaric spawn of
Satan that was absolutely unthinkable as
it turns out you now have within the
animal rights movement a substantial
feeling that there is a equation to be
made between eating animals and the
Holocaust this is in a book called
eternal Treblinka
I can't remember the author's name
nobody outside the Hal rights movement
reads the book but it's terribly
important to many people in the movement
their argument is that killing the Jews
is the same thing as eating steak or
pork chops or whatever that eating meat
is indistinguishable from running a
death camp it's just a different species
you have one species that are cows and
pigs and so forth and another species
that are Jews but but they're
indistinguishable so in this book you'll
have passages from the diaries of or
letters of extermination camp guards and
officials saying you know I'm working
here in Auschwitz and they really serve
a good steak then this will be as proof
that there's a mental moral conjunction
between killing humans and killing
animals
I made made made sports of this book in
my book hunters herders and hamburgers
and I got a substantial amount of
reaction that you know if I do not agree
with this that shows that I am part of
that I am someone who is morally
participating in the Holocaust so if you
are a meat-eater you are a Jew killer I
still don't agree with this but I do
recognize that within the within the
animal rights universe the argument that
killing humans and killing animals
are the boundary between them just as
the boundary between humans and animals
and speech and social organisations over
and so on
that this boundary is falling down and
you have the notion that it's all one
thing and it's all killing and it's all
wrong and everyone should be a vegan
from that point of view those Europeans
that came to the new world with their
herds of cattle and flocks yong-jo
flocks of sheep to eat them were no
different from excuse me we're no
different from the natives of the area
that practiced human sacrifice
in a hundred years
it would not shock me to discover that
there is a a revaluation of Eurasian
culture that emerges from the blurring
of the distinction between animal death
and human death
and those cultures that we tend to
disparage because they practiced human
sacrifice in such a an abundant and you
know seemingly gratuitously cruel
fashion they may seem less less
preposterous and indeed their human
sacrifice may simply be forgotten and
instead their glories will be what is
remembered now how do you forget that
well the same way that the gladiatorial
exploits of the Romans are things that
we know about everyone knows that
fighting to death to the death in the
arena for the entertainment of of the
crowd was a was not only common in the
Roman Empire it was one of the highest
things for the highest entertainment
said you could provide we all know that
that happened and in a world history we
mention it but we don't talk about the
Romans as as macro sacrificers of human
lives he said well they were very
warlike martial Rome they were warlike
people but of course having gladiators
fight in the arena or putting someone up
against wild animals so you can watch
them in torn apart or something like
that that isn't warlike that's barbaric
but the definition of barbarism
ironically excludes the Romans because
it's Romans who are the ones who in you
know use barbaric to talk about
everybody but the Romans they themselves
were civilized and had this quirk well
you know if we can forgive the Romans or
forget or look on Rome as a model for
the past model for the future from the
past in the way that Napoleon did when
he sort of resurrect to the Roman Empire
and the way in which Americans did when
they conceive of themselves as sort of
replicating the Roman Republic and then
you simply say well we'll forget about
that and this is one of the things about
about history and I think I find it
puzzling is the people who know the most
forget the most but they do it in a way
that is selective it's an educated
forgetting it's a decision not to
consider certain things but only to
consider others that fit into the the
broad story that you're trying to tell
throughout history this has been a
recurrent phenomenon to try to engineer
the past to decide what will be
remembered or what will not be
remembered or to decide among those
things that are remembered which ones we
choose to pay attention to and which
ones we choose to to ignore one of the
issues that came up in writing the
textbook and I believe I mentioned this
before is a question of whether people
who were not heterosexual should ever be
mentioned in the text no it's going to
be an AP text in high school you know
you don't want high school kids to think
that they're gay and lesbian people in
the world because they're innocent they
don't know these things well maybe they
do actually or maybe they hear it talked
about endlessly in public
Karina's these days but it still isn't
in the textbooks because the choice of
of the people from the from the erasure
planet was always not to mention this
and now historians come along they're
trying to recover it supposing you
recover it does that mean you mentioned
it I recall when a doctoral thesis being
written can't remember at what
university and it was about growing up
gay and Philadelphia in the 50s and the
thesis wasn't even done and the student
got an agent who was shopping the
unwritten thesis around to various
presses including university presses to
try and get a publisher because it was
so desperately needed it seemed at that
particular juncture to know what it was
like to be gay in Philadelphia in the
1950s I know it because we we considered
at a Columbia University Press when I
was on the publication committee and we
were saying well you know if we publish
what it was like to be gay in
Philadelphia in the 1950s then does that
mean we have to publish what it was like
to be gay in Toledo in the 1950s or to
be gay in you know in Portland the 1950s
or to be gay in st. Petersburg in the
1950s we what is it about this that
makes it important history well of
course the book was published and we did
at Columbia publish a book on what it
was like to be gay in Portland in the
1950s though we didn't publish the one
about Philadelphia
because inserting the the gay lesbian
transsexual bisexual perspective into
history is now a part of the profession
and so you want to create memories and
go back and find it in the history it
doesn't just am saying is here it's not
just a matter of
of Archaeology producing new knowledge
it's a matter of going back into known
archives and finding things that were
always there but we're not we're not
singled out there are many topics that
we know that existed that we don't we
don't write about eunuchs for example
you know lots and lots and lots of boys
were castrated and lived very important
lives in various societies we don't
really put this in the history books
very much unless we actually simply put
in the word eunuch because the
assumption is that high school kids
don't know what the word means and
therefore you can get away with it but
we certainly don't talk about that as an
industry although it was so I think that
what I'm getting to in all this but I
really have no idea what I'm getting to
in all this but but the thing is as I
think over this whole project of global
history I'm increasingly struck by by
how don't say capricious because it's
not capricious it was very specifically
and deliberately thought out what goes
in and what is left out now you can say
that that we do this by having themes
that the theme will dictate what goes in
and what gets left out but of course
every theme is subject to and to
interpretation as to what fits that
theme I remember when I wrote the
preface to the first edition I said that
on environment of Technology
I wrote that that the transmission of
empirical knowledge about an environment
constitutes a technology there to say
that if you if you know that such and
such plants will cure
or alleviate such and such ills or pains
that that passing on that information
from generation in generation
constitutes a technology and then having
people respond and say no a technology
must be a constructed item you know
chipping a stone is a technology
building a sailboat of the technology
designing a nuclear reactors technology
but simply the transmission of empirical
knowledge is not a technology and I I
thought that was wrong but I could see
the point because if you say that the
transmission of knowledge of empirical
knowledge is not a is a technology then
you can say that that magic and you know
all sorts of religious activities which
pass as being empirical knowledge and
are transmitted generations because they
have those are technologies and the
effort here was to was to separate the
material world from the you know from
the purely a conceptual world we now
think we now if people who go around the
world looking at the at the ethnobotany
of foraging people's everywhere in the
world they have huge bodies of lower
mostly now passing away having to do
with what plants do what or what animal
substances do what with respect to the
body so we we now or from suitable
companies now send people around to try
and collect that lore and test it and if
they find anything suggestive of
efficacy to reduce it to something
synthesizable and turn it into a
pharmaceutical project product that will
be a great discovery there will be a
great discovery by Pfizer not by the
people of New Guinea
that could have been done in many
respects before modern modern science
it's been known since Roman times at
least that that willow bark diminishes
pain and relieves fever it's mentioned
in Roman sources and various sources but
willow bark never became an important
terribly important phenomenon in Western
Europe in the Eurasia planet but in the
Western Hemisphere planet particularly
in North America
willow bark was commonly used as a as a
medicine so the Europeans come over you
know they're there they're living among
people who are using willow bark to
alleviate fever and pain and they don't
use it so then in the 1750s a clergyman
in England is walking along this is what
I believe is a true story he is walking
along and he's feeling you know some
sort of pain so he passes a willow tree
and he breaks off a piece of bark and
starts to chew it or suck on it and he
feels better but it's extremely bitter
and his thought is keep
the source of quinine in Peru is a
bitter bark and quinine we know is a
specific for the fever of malaria so
this bark of the willow is bitter and
maybe it's like that bark and Peru maybe
it is a good medicine it's been known to
be a good medicine for no 1,500 years by
that time except he didn't know it
because it doesn't become general and so
he takes some willow bark and chops it
up into a powder and turns it into pills
and gives it to friends who have fevers
and they say oh it was pretty good stuff
and that was a salicylic acid which is
was then combined with another product
from the spiraea plant in order to
lessen the disturbance to the stomach
and it became a cetyl salicylic acid and
that's aspirin which is by many accounts
the most important medicine ever
discovered
now it could have been discovered 200
years earlier if people had observed
what they were doing in the Western
Hemisphere planet so the the passage of
knowledge from generation of generation
I think really is something that we
could have subsumed under this theme of
environment of technology but we tended
to to not do it as systematically as we
should have but even if we had the story
of Miss connections and of a lack of
lack of just a simple curiosity about
people on the other planets would have
stood in the way and final example that
comes to mind is the Aborigines in
Australia the Aborigines in Australia
have been of interest to anthropologists
ethnographers for a long time
particularly because of their adoption
of animal totems and so on and they're
pretty well well discussed and then they
became completely differently discussed
within the last twenty years because it
was discovered that there were rock
paintings in Australia that were datable
and the dates were thirty thousand years
earlier than people thought there's a
debate as to whether the earliest
paintings on rock and Australia go back
only to 40,000 BC or 40,000 years before
the present or whether they actually go
back to 60,000 years you get a debate on
that but the oldest modern human remains
outside of East Africa in terms of the
evidence of a culture as opposed to the
bones because we haven't found bones at
all but the oldest what remains happen
to be in Australia then suddenly
Australia becomes a topic of a
fascination humans get there so early
and are so satisfied with not building a
civilization that it raises this
question of why you know how could so
many tens of thousands of years go by
and still have the aboriginal culture of
Australia being what it was when the
Europeans
I finally encountered it as long as they
were as they didn't have a deep
chronological past they could be pretty
much marginalized and trivialized now
they have to be accounted for because
this is the sort of thing that that new
knowledge does so what I'm concluding
really here is that the notion of a
global history that it all comes
together is is sort of fraudulent
because it's only one globe that comes
together and we still tend to to dismiss
and to to disparage the other globes
that that existed at one time that still
exists the other planets but we just we
dismiss in disparage the the forms that
they took when those forms were not
consonant with the with the dominant
cultures of Eurasia and then I would say
that in the future this will change and
that I think we will find great
questions being being raised about the
date you know where the central the most
important aspects of world history are
and what those important most important
aspects are though it may take another
hundred years another hundred years to
do it so I'm skeptical about the notion
of taking globalisation as something
good and more inclined to think that
globalization will have to be something
that has overcome that globalization
will become what European exceptionalism
was early in the 20th century a concept
that has to be overcome to recognize the
rest of the world and I think that
globalization is going to become an
obstacle
rather than
rather than a Telos rather than a final
result of a world history and how that's
going to happen I I don't obviously know
but it certainly is going to raises the
promise that in another 50 years we
might be able to write a something like
the earth and its people's that will be
not a world history but a world's
history and that it will be very
different and globalization will be seen
as a as kind of a know a false a false
god then the other perspective of course
is that the internet will change
everything and we have another another
plan to be heard of and it's going to be
a virtual planet that will supplant
everything we've known before but you
know I don't want to go there in
particular but in any case you know I
started out first thinking about world
history and in the early 80s it's been
almost 30 years I have now taught the
course once I'm not going to teach it
again and I appreciate all the attention
that you've paid me during the semester
thank you
you